make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this
is rob and uh we are back with venom
beyond here's the thing man i
i love the way that donnie kates writes
this right because i fired this book up
and i say within the span of five
minutes i was done right i just ripped
through this book and to me that's a
testament of how good a comic book is
right if i can just like if i find
myself just ripping through it and i
feel like i'm done before i even started
that's just how good the comic book is
written
right so um this kind of gives us at
least as much as donnie kate's gives us
anyway the way in which the world fell
under the rule of venom sun we're not
given a whole ton of stuff here and in
reality we probably don't need to be but
the idea here
is that at some point in the past in
this alternate reality
that there was you basically had you
know an ann wayne who of course was
possessed by her venom symbiote and more
or less operating as what what amounts
to agent venom alongside spider-man who
ended up defeating doctor octopus right
in some campaign that was called octopi
wall street
it was kind of goofy but ann wayne
basically reveals that she's pregnant
here now this is what's kind of bonkers
is donnie cates doesn't necessarily seem
to have
given us the indication that eddie brock
is the one who got her pregnant it's
just simply that eddie brock you know
was
eddie brock and her were married at one
point in a relationship if we follow the
you know a reasonable timeline here we
don't definitively know when it was that
eddie brock shot himself we're not told
here in this particular comic that like
three days after eddie brock shot
himself you know we're not really told
that instead it's just eddie brock ended
up killing himself in the bell tower and
then anne went there and she ended up
getting the venom symbiote right so we
don't really know how much time has
passed
i would expect that under most
circumstances whenever a woman realizes
she's pregnant it's usually because as
she goes through her
womanly times that she realizes that
she's not doing the things she's
supposed to be doing and
as a result of that we can largely
assume that at most a month has passed
since eddie brock died by whatever
manner in whatever means
if we assume that eddie brock is the one
or got her pregnant then that makes
sense
we could also kind of assume that she
was that it's like a miraculous
conception right that like the symbiote
ultimately just ended up creating an
offspring inside of her ah again we're
not giving a definitive answer here we
just kind of have to swing for the
fences because when she's sitting down
with peter parker and she tells peter
parker that she's pregnant when he asks
who the father is
she's like i don't know now the third
option here is that anne's just really
promiscuous and like any number of guys
out there could be the dad right we just
don't know right it's like an episode of
maury povich right you bring like 20
guys on there none of them are the
father right you have no idea which one
it is you know it's just so that's
that's also an option too right but
whatever it is she ended up being
pregnant and of course
that was dylan right she ended up being
you know getting pregnant and having
dylan the crazy thing about this is
peter parker basically talks about hey
like you know it's going to be tough
being a single mom i was kind of raised
there but if you ever need any help i'm
here and her response is i'm not a
single mom right i have venom and so
like between the two of us we can raise
this kid to become
you know a productive member of society
right we'll just be fun you know
we'll be just fine and so what you end
up finding out here is that as time
passed
and dylan grew up and got to the age
that he is now in the main marvel
universe
that he grew up as any kind of a normal
kid does right he had his
good moments his bad moments right you
know kids misbehave they push brown uh
push boundaries different things like
that you know and so he did what any
normal kid does but then one day she
came home
and all those different drawings were on
the walls right the the drawings of like
the grendel and that's kind of the
telltale signature of like
null the symbiote god and so what she
basically shows here is that at some
point along the line
that null ended up taking over dylan
right now this i believe
is shown in in a one-shot comic that
focuses on null basically getting his
hands on dylan
and and influencing him and actually
teaching him how to use his powers or at
least teaching him the base on how his
powers work and then the rest was kind
of left to dylan from there but one of
the things to keep in mind for those of
you guys who are a little behind here
know the symbiote god was donnie kate's
invention and what he basically did is
he introduced this idea
that where brian michael bendis had
previously given us this explanation of
the symbiotes in the sense that venom
was not a one-off right the venom
actually comes from a planet of
symbiotes and those symbiotes are
ideally space knights right so they
basically bond themselves to a host and
they go forward
as protectors of the universe that
sometimes a symbiote can be corrupted
and that's what happened that in the
original secret wars peter parker came
in contact with a symbiote and he was
supposed to be a space knight of sorts
right like a protector using the
symbiote the result was that once he was
told by reed richards in the old web of
spiderman comics that the symbiote was
an actual sentient being and that the
things that peter was doing
were basically because the symbiote was
acting in acting of his own accord that
peter cast it off and in doing so
that corrupted the venom symbiote and
that's how it ended up becoming quote
unquote a bad guy and then basically
bonded itself to eddie brock later on
and that's the whole history of venom in
the the
you know in the main marvel universe the
idea was that when donnie kate came
along
donnie kate said everything that brian
michael been to say with the planet of
the symbiotes is still intact but i'm
adding on to it and he created
null and null was the person who created
the symbiotes in the first place he
created them as basically his henchmen
and that once null was ultimately
defeated and kind of cast back into the
void or at least you know
kind of locked within his own his own
planet more or less and surrounded by
all these symbiotes the symbiotes then
in turn
became more or less autonomous and
that's when they formed their idea of
becoming protectors as opposed to
henchmen of knoll with null basically
re-emerging in the aftermath
of absolute carnage that null began to
exercise his control over the symbiotes
yet again that's really where this comes
from in the sense that null basically
reached out from his place within the
multiverse and has influenced this
version of dylan
and basically taken him over right in
the sense that like dylan now kind of
operates seemingly as an agent of null
and the result of this is that he ended
up taking a piece of his mom's symbiote
and then used it to create his own
symbiote following that he ended up
taking off to a different location
and this is this is kind of us reading
between the lines or at least from what
what anne's telling us that he ended up
going to basically the bell tower and
then in turn
started spawning off all these different
symbiotes and then controlling them and
then rejecting them and this was
designed for the purpose of him
basically
creating symbiotes and then kind of
usurping his control over those
symbiotes and sending them forward in
response to this growing symbiote threat
president flash thompson ended up
creating ann weighing and the
agent venom force more or less and in
doing that the idea was to take on the
forces of dylan the issue here
is that by the time they realized that
dylan was literally a credible threat
it was simply too late that with these
symbiotes he had created he had
basically
forced them onto the superheroes and
some of the super villains and turned
them into a symbiote henchmen and so he
literally
laid waste to virtually any other
superhero and villain that was left
right killed pretty much
all the superheroes and all the super
villains on earth following that and
with the death of president flash
thompson dylan essentially made himself
a dictator right he made himself
absolute ruler of the earth and then
sent his symbiotes around the world
and started basically taking over
everybody around there right like the
average person and that's what that's
kind of what anne says
is that dylan killed the world that he
essentially conquered the world by using
venom symbiotes and that's why this is
just a venomized world right all the
heroes all the villains
are all symbiotes now some of these
heroes are actually heroes who have been
taken over by symbiotes some of these
heroes are just venom symbiotes looking
like heroes right like you know kind of
appearing as these individuals it's kind
of a mishmash of these different things
but the long and short of this is that
the concern of anne
is that dylan could essentially fall
down the same way and this comes in a
couple different forms the first one
this takes
is her asking eddie does dylan have
these powers now keep in mind this is a
highly emotional situation for anne
because
one like she lost her son right she lost
her son to the power of null and there
doesn't really seem to be a way to bring
him back
the other part of this is that she is
kind of emotionally tied to eddie brock
this is not her eddie brock but this is
in a lot of ways kind of the eddie she
could have had right in a lot of ways
they're
a mirror for the life that she lost and
so that's when she asked the question
like
does your son have that same power and
the response of eddie is yes he can do
that but he won he can't really be taken
over by symbiotes it creates a kind of
feedback
feedback loop and ultimately it causes
him pain but two he's not an evil guy
he's he's not a bad kid he's not a
villain in the way that your son was it
sucks to say that but he's not that way
now the issue with this is that dylan
overhears everything right like like the
the main marvel universe dylan overhears
them all
and for him it's kind of crushing right
it's crushing to hear that this
alternate reality version of himself
became such a horrible person right that
essentially took over the world and that
there's a concern that he could become
that exact same kind of person right
it's like if you were met with an
alternate reality counterpart of
yourself who was just a horrible human
being and the concern of everybody that
you knew is that you would become that
person right there's a part of you that
screams out i'm not that guy i'm not
going to be that person
but dylan has never really met his mom
right he never really met met ann
i mean she gave birth to him but like
she ran off to to uh to eddie brock's
dad and drop the kid off there when he
was a baby and then went and did herself
in right and so he's never actually met
his mom and this one woman that he sees
you know that that is the closest he
ever came to meeting his mom has
essentially rejected him this is
emotionally crushing for really all
parties involved here
the caveat to this is that as they're
sitting down and as ann could just kind
of says look i can't really do this this
is too much and as she begins to leave
she's met by venompool and he's like you
guys have to go and it's like why and
it's like because they tracked us here
like they they tracked you guys to your
base of operations right like you guys
gotta get out of here as fast as you
possibly can because they're sending
someone here to take you out and as soon
as she you know as soon as his anne
calls in the sos then suddenly
you have scorpion who pops in now
remember matt gargan was
operating as virus at the start of this
story right he is the main marvel
universe version of matt gargan who has
basically been taken over by a symbiote
of sorts that was given to him by or at
least impose on him by
by codex in order to track down eddie
and then bring him to
bring him to the dylan and of course
kill everybody else and the issue with
this is like as soon as they show up all
hell breaks loose the caveat to this
is that eddie brock is aware that the
weakness of symbiotes comes in the form
of like
sonics or huge amounts of electricity or
fire and so what he ends up doing
is grabbing like these live electric
lines just grabs them and rereads like
like those are electrical currents right
like no one can survive
any of that any of that kind of energy
his response is yeah that's what we're
counting on so he basically channels it
through himself and shoots it out in
what it what
the venom symbiote creates as a hand
cannon and basically takes out mac right
takes out matt gargan then he calls on
his son do your thing
and dylan seizes the symbiote off of off
of scorpion takes total control of it
and then basically matt gargan reverts
back to his normal self right this is a
genius maneuver but it's also
exceedingly dangerous because the more
that dylan uses his powers the more
susceptible to null he becomes
and that would allow null to reach in
now one thing if i'm being honest with
you guys
one thing that i think is really kind of
going on here is wouldn't it be
interesting if donnie kate's followed
the jonathan hickman
avengers new avengers molecule man
concept right in the sense that during
avengers and new avengers most of you
guys know there was one molecule man in
every reality and that origin of
molecule man was the exact same but he
was designed to be a bomb
that the beyonders were going to
detonate all at the same time and
destroy the multiverse right but
wouldn't it be interesting
if it were the same concept with dylan
that every universe has its own version
of dylan and dylan is unique among you
know in
every single universe in the sense that
while his origins not the exact same
although it may be in some way that he
has these powers the ability to dominate
the wills of symbiotes he is in effect a
kind of indirect error to null right he
possesses
essentially the same powers that null
does even if not on such a grandiose
scale
and that by having that kind of power it
allows null to basically take over dylan
which allows him to control the
symbiotes across
every world wouldn't that be interesting
right every world and every universe but
as far as mag gargan goes you know of
course when when the the symbiotes torn
off of him and eddie realizes it's matt
gargan then we kind of get a little bit
of an explanation here right and the
idea is that during absolute carnage but
as you guys remember
matt gargan's spine was almost totally
ripped out and he was basically
paralyzed and eddie left him there
right and and eddie just left him there
you got to go well
he ended up taking off and leaving him
there and that's why matt gargan holds
so much animosity because he's like you
don't forget like you don't get to just
walk away from the fact that you left me
paralyzed like that now admittedly
matt gargan was going to let like an
innocent kid die right so you know at
the end of the day eddie brock's like i
was kind of right for what i did but the
response of mac is you basically left me
there that way i could have recovered if
i'd had a symbiote or something like
that but i couldn't
right like you just left me paralyzed
there and walked away and so the
response of eddie and this is really
interesting the response of eddie is
fine then we'll make you a deal
right i'm going to make you a deal here
my son just killed the symbiote that was
attached to you from codex right so what
we're going to do is you're
going to take us to codex and then
seemingly the bargain is you know i will
give you a symbiote or something like
that and you'll regain your ability to
walk you know i don't really know what
the bargain is but the idea is
you are going to take us to codex and so
seemingly dylan is going to meet his
alternate reality counterpart and who
even
knows what's gonna come out of that
conflict i have no earthly clue because
maybe we'll get even more of an origin
story
about codex right and that's why it's
kind of tentative here maybe we'll get a
lot more information because we still
got two issues i think until this whole
thing's done so with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like
i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you